Mayuko Inoue: Hey everybody, how's it going? My name is
Mayuko and welcome back to my channel.
So on this channel, I shared a lot of my own tips about how to get that coveted first job
as a software engineer in the tech industry,
but in an effort to just like invite more voices to my channel and really provide like good industry tips and experiences and stuff.
I had a recruiter on my show Muko's corner to talk about the inside scoop about the recruiting process.
I talked to Sarah, who's the lead negotiator at levels.fyi and she's also a former recruiter at Amazon, Facebook, and Google.
So she really knows her stuff. In the show, we talked about how the recruiting process works from the
inside,
which you can watch in the card linked up above. But in this video, I'm going to share with you the tips that she mentioned on the show,
about how to get that first job. I mean, she's someone who's
definitely seen like 10s, if not hundreds of 1000s of applications.
So she really knows like the do's and
don'ts of like what to do to get that first job.
So I'm gonna be sharing highlights from that show where we'll
talk about things like how to stand out as an applicant,
how to prepare for the tech interview, and more, I know that like, I definitely would have benefited so much from this information in college.
So I hope this helps you as well. And thank you to Brilliant for sponsoring today's video.
So let's dive in. Now let's walk through the kind of interview process.
And I'm going to walk us through specifically from a candidates perspective, because I think a lot of the people viewing
this are kind of on the candidate
side. So I guess step 0 is applying to the role like that's,
we're gonna zero indexing that's, that's what we have to do first.
So what's the most like,
recommended tactic
for how new grads should go about
applying to jobs?  Um, I think I want to also tap into kind of like
the trade off between quality versus
quantity, like, should I be applying to 200 jobs a week?
Or should I be building relationships with specific people and really working hard at a couple or a few applications?
Sarah: Yeah, so in terms of like, I would say, number
one thing is stay updated with your social media,
because when a job open, like I said earlier, it goes
really fast. And some company choose to take it down
after two weeks, because the amount of applicants they
have, it's just insane. And so make sure that you stay
updated a lot of company like Salesforce, Microsoft,
and Amazon put a lot of events together, go to those
because for a recruiter, and I've done events, like a
few times at Amazon, where if you show up to those
event, we want to reward you, we want to thank you for
taking the time to come in and you know, interact with
like our team. So sometimes to you automatically get
like a link to for the take home assignment versus like
someone who didn't go to the event, they would have to
apply. And then you're kind of now relying on a
recruiter to click yes on your application and send
that link to you. versus if you go to their events, you
automatically get that first link. And then if you pass
that, that's when the recruiter will work with you in
terms of like, moving you through the first process.
It's really, I mean, I feel like take home assignment
just have like such a bad rep to it. But because we're
offering so much in terms of like volume, we just want
to make sure that we're spending our time a little bit
more productive and efficiently here, we want to talk
to a candidate who can, you know, at least pass like
the computer science fundamentals. So go to those
events, even Google have a lot of events to either live
or even on their YouTube channel, watch those video in
terms of like what the interviewers are looking for.
The company did spend a lot of time and effort to put
together those like material for a candidate. And the
second thing is, there's a lot more different revenue
that a recruiter would have to go and look for
candidate, not just applicants alone, like I mentioned
earlier, and we're like, where do we look for candidate
number one is going to be LinkedIn. So make sure that
your LinkedIn profile is optimized with keywords. And
it's really, I mean, I have so many friends that come
to me and say like, well, I've been like applying to so
many different jobs and like no one ever got back to
me. And when I looked at their resume or their LinkedIn
profile, like I can't tell that they are software
engineer because the title would be something like,
member of technical staff or something technical, but
I'm just like, are you a software engineer? Are you not
a software engineer, I'm confused. And there were like,
that's a reason why recruiter can't find you because
that isn't software engineer anywhere on your
application. So make sure that you optimize your
LinkedIn that's the biggest thing and then number 3 is
I love Triplebyte at Facebook, I would go to triplebyte
to source for candidates and a lot of companies are you
know, have the same thing to another website would be
like hire.com. So beyond just LinkedIn, be a little bit
more creative about you know where else that you can
get that yes from the recruiter. And with Triplebyte to
like, as a company. We have to pay money to look for a
candidate, so like you know, spend the time to kind of
do the tests and things like that. Hackerrank also is
another good resource to0, and then build a
relationship with people. hackathon would be a really
great way to ramp up your resume. If you don't have any
experience, build relationship in terms of, you know,
maybe another hiring manager or another software
engineer. I would say the best way to really utilize
your LinkedIn is don't just reach out to manager, don't
just reach out to the recruiter, reached out to someone
who was once in your shoes. Let's say if I come across
and say I want to be a software engineer, and I go
through LinkedIn, or Facebook, for example, and I saw
someone have been at Facebook for one year, I would
want to reach out to that person and ask, Hey, I came
across your profile. And you know, what you're doing is
very inspiring. And I saw that you've been at Facebook
for one year, you know, is it possible for us to
connect, I would love to learn more about how the
process was like for you, what else that I can learn
from you. And like that person's more inclined to say,
Yes, I'll talk to you because that person isn't
bombarded with like 500 messages per day from on
LinkedIn. And like they are more relatable and like,
what advice that they can give you is a lot more
relatable too. So I would say instead of reaching out
to a hiring manager or recruiter, do reach out to the
people that once were in your shoes.
Mayuko Inoue: That makes a lot of sense. Wow, so many
good tips just Okay, wait, I want to click into some of
these things. So the first thing that you said was, the
first tip was going to events like going to events that
like companies put on at their campus, which totally
makes sense. I've been on the side of like helping put
these events on. And it takes work and effort and
resources and time and money. And so of course, you're
going to reward the people who go because recruiting
from the company side is not cheap. Like it takes so
much effort to get that thing to happen, I guess, for
anybody who, you know, wants to find out about these
events, but is having trouble doing so do you have an
advice? Do you have any advice for like, how do you
even find out about these events that are happening on
your campus?
Sarah: LinkedIn. So on the company page, like LinkedIn
would be like the best way to kind of stay updated.
Another thing would be the YouTube channel. Because
like Google would announce all day event on YouTube.
And then the last one is going to be Eventbrite. I
think I use Eventbrite at Amazon. And yeah, to your
point earlier, it takes a lot of work to put an event
together. And from a recruiter perspective, like, I
know that my upper management will ask me in terms of
like ROI and metrics, I can't just put together an
event, and there isn't a way for me to measure my ROI
unless if I send candidates that take home assignment,
and then from their present, you know, like, Oh, we put
out this event, and it cost us this much. And on top of
that, we ended up getting X amount of candidates, and
then here's our conversion rate. So like, that's the
only way for us to, you know, measure our ROI. So that
would be like the best way for you to get noticed. For
for your resume, and kind of like get through that
round of the interview.
Mayuko Inoue: That makes sense. Yeah, for those of you
not familiar with ROI that's return on investment. So
yeah, it's like, anytime a company puts on stuff,
they're investing money and resources on something. So
they want that return in some way. And if it's a
recruiting event, they're literally looking for
candidates to hire, or at least just spread the word
about a company, because maybe, you know, they filled
out headcount, but they still want people to know that
this is a company that will hire next year, next
season, or they're looking for a specific kind of
person. So that's super helpful to know. Okay, the
second tip that you provided was updating your LinkedIn
and making sure that it looks good, like you have all
the keywords and stuff. And one of the things you
mentioned was, like making sure that it looks like you
have the word software developer, software engineer on
it. And I was just thinking about it. Like, from a
student's perspective, for someone who hasn't worked
full time before, as a software developer, I know that
there's this hesitancy to be like, I've never been paid
to be a software engineer anymore, like before, can I
call myself a software engineer? So I know that that
can be kind of like a crisis that people can have,
especially in that tagline of like, what is your role?
And who are you? Um, do you feel like if you've never
had a full time role before is it okay to put that in
the job description? Like, is it okay to be like, this
is what I'm shooting for. So this is who I am. Is that
an okay tactic?
Sarah: Yeah, so in terms of like, how would you
identify yourself, right, because LinkedIn is not like
a resume. It's not like a legally binding contract is
just another platform of social media. Like I can call
myself whatever I want on Instagram. But you probably
want to be more strategic about like what you put on
your LinkedIn and there's that "About" section That you
can be very specific about, you know, your software
engineer, aspiring software engineer, and then what
type of engineering that you specialize in. Are you
full stack web or you backend, are you Python? And I
really love when I go through a LinkedIn profile and
they tell me that like, I'm a back and web development
engineer or something like that. And then in that about
section, you can do a lot with keywords, it doesn't
have to be from the experience alone, and in terms of
experiences, so many way for you to kind of get that
experience too. I know that from Microsoft, if you just
do like a few hackathons, they count that as
experience. Another way for you to ramp up your
experience is open source projects, you actually get to
interact with engineers that are in the company, you
get to learn about like, Okay, I have to make sure that
my code is it makes sense. And if my code wouldn't
break, like their code, and things like that, and I
know a lot of my friends was able to leverage open
source to get jobs, full time position, even for self
taught folks too. Then another way is internship or any
project that you have, you can call yourself software
engineer, the name of the project, and then kind of
bullet points like your accomplishment. What did you
do? And how did you get to that point?
Mayuko Inoue: So Sarah, from your perspective, what can
students do to prepare for their interviews?
Sarah: When you get to the final interview, a lot of
people just have this misconception that they have to
be really good in tech, and the interview, which is
centered around like leet coding questions. Actually,
the answer is not really I've had engineers who maybe
didn't do so well, on the tech side, but they
demonstrate really good soft skill, and they ended up
getting an offer. So when you get to that final stage,
the company will index on both tech and soft skill. So
for the soft skills, I'm just going to touch on this
really quickly. A lot of students didn't prepare for
this portion. And the question is usually the format of
can you tell me about a time that you x? What did you
do? What was the end outcome? And a lot of people
didn't come prepare for this. And a lot of students
ended up sharing like personal story about maybe a time
that they overcome hardship, or overcome challenges and
things like that, as an interviewer, I can't document
that, from a legal perspective, if you share anything
personal, I might just have to kind of acknowledge that
in the interview setting like thank you for sharing
that. Do you have a different example? And usually,
when I asked that question, or interviewers asked that
question, we want concrete example of a time that it
actually happened and how you navigated that situation.
And 80% of the students that I talked to, they would
give me hypothetical example of like, oh, if it
happened, I would do this. And I would just have to
remind them like, Okay, did it happen? Can you tell me
something that actually happened. So prepare for those
example would be super helpful, I would say, keep in,
you know, in the back of your mind, like, prepare like
five to seven examples. And then make sure that you
structure them in a STAR method. And that stands for
situation, task, action, and results. Make sure that
you prepare and rehearse it a few times, so that you
don't end up like rambling during the interview. And so
and then be prepared for follow up questions, too. This
is another thing where, let's say ask that question.
Tell me about a time ABCD. And I just wanted to ask
follow up questions. And the student just thought that
they did something wrong, or the answer wasn't correct.
And they just completely like, shut down. So I've seen
that happen a lot. It's like it's very normal. The
interviewer just want to ask more follow up question,
just so that we can write clear feedback in order to
you know, make a case for you later, we think that
you're a strong candidate. So don't freak out when that
happened. And then on the tech side, I mean, obviously
you leet code, but the thing is, if you have the
cleanest solution, but you couldn't talk through it,
you probably wouldn't get a yes from the interviewer.
So usually from an interviewer would look for A. that
this candidate at asked good clarifying questions. And
the questions are usually really ambiguous. It's
designed that way, because they want you to ask those
question first before you jump into problem solving
mode. And then before you even, after you ask a
clarifying question, be sure to talk through your
thought process, and then be open to hints and
feedback. So this is the biggest thing. We know that
you don't have a lot experience. We're gonna have to
coach you. We're going to have to mentor you, we're
going to have to develop you. And the biggest thing
that we look for here is not the cleanest solution.
We're looking for how coachable you are, and a lot of
the times that interviewer will try to give hints or
see if you know, if this candidate is stuck, are they
proactive about asking for hints? Are they practical
about asking for help? And there are so many times when
the interviewer tried to give hints. And the student or
the candidate just didn't listen at all, and they just
kept going. So then from an interviewer perspective,
they now raise an issue of, well, I may have an issue
with coachability, because I tried to give him so many
hints and they didn't listen. So you don't need to have
like the best answer, make sure that you communicate,
ask clarifying question, talk through your thought
process, open to hints and feedback. So those are like
the three things that you always need to do in the
technical interview.
Mayuko Inoue: That makes sense, it turns out that
there's a lot of soft skills that comes through even in
the technical interview. So one of the things I think
about is just like Cracking the Coding interview book,
right, that everybody studies from all the time, the
behavioral part is like this, then versus the technical
stuff is like this thing, but in reality, it's actually
a part of everything else. And sometimes the behavioral
stuff is weighted, at least equally, if not more than
the technical side. So thank you so much for sharing
that for someone who just like, doesn't really know
exactly what kind of role they want to go into. Is it
better for them to choose and say, like, okay, you
know, I don't really know. But I think backend, Sure,
let's do backend, because I liked my backend class the
most. Is it better to do that? Or is it better to like,
talk about all of your breadth of experiences, and kind
of just be like, I like everything, help. From a
recruiters perspective, what works better?
Sarah: From a recruiter perspective, I would say, as
you know, I mean, you can explore, but in terms of like
a resume and LinkedIn perspective, think of it as like,
is your marketing, your branding, your brochure, you
want to put like the best on there, right? And from a
recruiter perspective, when I have when I see too many
question mark on a resume, I usually just pass on that
resume, because I just don't want to hop on a call with
someone and then ask them those questions. And they say
no, and then it would be like, Okay, I have to reject
you. Like it's safer for me to just pass and not being
put in a difficult situation to reject that candidate
later. And another thing too, is, I know that if a
resume has too many things going on, and I present that
resume to my hiring manager, they will tell me No. So I
already know what my manager is going to say. And
therefore I also will reject that resume. Another thing
too, is like whatever you put on your resume is fair
game. If you only took a course on Coursera, about
machine learning and AI, please don't claim that you
are machine learning and AI engineer on your resume.
Because we do have a meeting before the interview
happened. And all of the interviewers will look at this
resume and say, okay, based on this resume, we want to
calibrate you correctly, we want to ask the right
questions. And let's say I have this incident happened
where one of the candidate for whatever reason other
team didn't say yes to this person, and the machine
learning and AI team decided to say yes to this
candidate, and they ended up tailor the interview, just
around like machine learning and AI like domain
specific and this candidate didn't do so well. So
whatever you put on your resume, just know that they
might ask you or bring it up during the interview
process. So you want to be good at one thing, instead
of like, 10 different things. And then you know, half
the interview not to go so well.
Mayuko Inoue: That makes total sense. Like I think of
the analogy of just like if you go to a restaurant, and
they're like, you know, we can do Japanese food, we can
do Korean food, we can do Italian food and Spanish food
and Mexican food, you're probably not gonna go to that
restaurant, because it's probably that like, none of
that is super good. versus if you really are just like,
you know what? Korean food like that's what I super
love to make. That's what I super love to eat. And
that's what this restaurant is about, then the mental
model is there, the branding is there, and people are
more likely to be like, yeah, Korean food cool, instead
of this mix of like many things, and you're just like,
I don't really know what you're about. So that makes
complete sense to me.
Sarah: From a management perspective, when you don't
have like a focus, it's really hard for that manager to
say yes to you, because they have to think of like,
okay, hire this person, how can I best utilize this
person on my team? What project are they going to be
working on? So when you like, have a little bit of
everything from a planning perspective is really hard
for the hiring manager and therefore, they might just
say, No, I want someone who's a little bit more
specialized in one thing.
Mayuko Inoue: Thank you all so much for watching. I
hope this information was helpful. Sarah shared a lot
of amazing insights when she was on my show movers
corner that I definitely learned a lot from so to watch
the video recording you can become a member today by
clicking the Join button down below and get full access
to that episode and many others. I have also created
highlight videos from those conversations with Sarah,
so I'll link them all down below about the recruiting
process as well as salary negotiations. And also, if
you'd like to listen to the audio recording of my
conversation with Sarah, it'll be on the podcast
version of Muko's corner, I want to take a moment to
thank the sponsor of today's video Brilliant. An
important part of getting that first job is to really
understand fundamental computer science topics such as
data structures and algorithms. And Brilliant is a
wonderful site to help you do that. Brilliant is a
problem solving based website and app the hands on
approach with over 60 interactive courses in math,
science, and computer science. They all have an element
of storytelling, code writing, interactive challenges,
and problem solving as part of their courses. You can
use Brilliant to get into the habit of learning new
things every day or using it to reinforce existing
lessons like data structures and algorithms. I think
the courses that they have on there are really amazing
and they really help you to fully understand the
concepts through all of the interactive storytelling.
So make sure to check out Brilliant today by going to
brilliant.org/hellomayuko, where the first 200 people
will get 20% off of the annual premium subscription.
Alright, everybody, thank you so much for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe, and I'll see you next time.
Bye.